[Music]
maybe used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes skip locks we used to be so
connected he did smile you know you can
experience things a whole lot better
without that game that this is how I
experiencing I don't think tomorrow I'm
finally leaving for college but in the
meantime I made you guys to survive it
yeah you know what this is our last
night together how about we make ten
seconds family hi contact starting with
your go down now no you're allowed to
blink it's just my contacts
oh no screens at the table Lynn why are
you kicking me I don't understand I'm
just you know look I'll watch it dad
it's too late I want to watch it okay
this is exactly why I'm excited to leave
tomorrow
lady I know you can fix this
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport
I can't load your plane ticket to
college we are gonna drive you to school
on a cross-country road trip as a family
behold and now I present shrieking hey
Dad can you check the trunk yeah sure
go get Katie the kids they're supposed
to be some great hikes around here this
is something we hear a pal bout to drop
our biggest invention yet meet the
helper part we promise you they will
never turn either mom what is that
greetings humans technology rising up
sayonara robots roaming the streets what
is this strange creature dog pick dog
loaf of bread let me just have always
been weird
fun to watch your hands don't worry I
never do that's what makes us great then
we just might be weird enough to save
the world all right
[Music]